well the good day team we're all over
all those rising prices at gas stations
and grocery stores we know it impacts
all of us so we started a campaign in
cooperation with conoco and i surprised
a conoco customer last week by gifting
him a good day
we know the price of gas just keeps
going higher and higher and so eight
news now and conoco are about to give
someone a good day with free gas we're
going to surprise somebody let's go
i bet maximus down at the conoco station
on south rainbow in the mountains edge
neighborhood told us he's peeling the
gas price pain in his pocket we're
asking folks about high gas prices i'm
guessing you've noticed that it's
getting a little more expensive to fill
up the tank yeah it costs like 40
dollars to fill up a ford focus a couple
months ago it was only 30. he thought we
were only interviewing about the
increase in gas prices little did he
know it was his lucky day we're gonna
throw a little surprise at you here
maximus we're paying for your gas today
maximus you're getting a good day from
eight news now
thank you so much man maximus
congratulations
i think he was stunned silent
you were more excited than he was that's
really funny but he also had some other
buddies with him in the car they were
inside the store shopping and when they
came out it was like dude i got free gas
oh man that's great like the african
culture well i think we've all been on
these little missions here and it is fun
to watch people
you know you realize it kind of made
their day yeah it makes a difference i
would take the money anytime
all of that we all could use a little
help i wanted
his name maximus
might have spent all the extra money on
doritos but i'm not sure hey no judgment
again
we gifted him a good day sure did taki's
in the store okay